well last year we saw a really bloody
event with nobody really fully rising to
the top and Wesley kind of fought
through it and deservedly won so I think
we might see something like that again a
lot of bloody fights and a lot of
players who who will have their chances
to win and it's just a question of who
will take their chances it's hard to
predict what's gonna happen I just have
to give my best and play my best try to
play well no no I don't think anyone can
really say before tournament starts that
they're gonna win it I don't have any
special goals
I just want to actually play well I
think I played well probably the last
two years before not last year last year
I didn't play very well
my last few tournaments before this I've
done pretty well actually so I'm just
trying to keep that momentum going and
keep that upward trend going
historically I haven't done too well
here although I've definitely had some
good years and I just hope that my time
time is the charm no no big plans
you know just win one game will be nice
to start with and we'll see them you
know I'm very good at adjusting it sort
of it goes well I can go for and or more
for you know like I did last year but if
it won't go well then then you know
winning from time to time would be nice
I don't have like precise gold that I
need to accomplish this or that but I
just want to play well and see how it
goes any time you have new faces it's
certainly it's it's refreshing and it's
always exciting to play against people
that you've never faced before so I'm
certainly looking forward to playing
against a wonder and jeffer as well for
me every year it's just try to gain
experience and enjoy every single game I
play here I guess definitely just want
to enjoy the game and have fun
throughout the tournament gain
experience you know um have fun playing
and strong players and you know just see
how it goes the US Championship keeps
getting stronger and stronger but I I
would love to regain my title from 2016
I think it's a huge accomplishment there
would also be a point of pride for me
[Music]
you